how long to go this is New London  everyone's happy yeah  everyone has a place there's no hunger  no violence  there's no pain there John  everyone fits  I've always wanted that for you  [Music]  this is your home now  [Music]  Embrace this place and let it be  wonderful  okay  all you have to do  everyone belongs to everyone else  you're never alone here everyone's  connected  you know I've been watching you people  but this place is so perfect  why is it upside down  there is a disruption I just can't seem  to get back to myself  virus enters a cell turning the body  against itself  we need to stop this before this goes  too far  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]